there is no mod the open model Warriors
Are Climbing at the gates scaling The
Benchmark and more importantly the
hearts of their users in the past CH
months more than 50,000 AI models have
been uploaded to Hing phase per month
and is accelera that is more than one AI
model a minute meaning by the end of
this talk today that's another 500
models
alone however not all models are equal
the whe that crash into the room is DC
R1 the first open source model to catch
up and surpass GPD 4 proving that you do
not need a billion dollars to compete
with the big laps just a little smart
and Prudence to catch up with over 4
million downloads of a 685 GB model on
huging face this past month alone this
one model exceeds over 2.74 exabytes of
data moving across the internet a number
so ridiculously large that will take my
fast 1 GB internet 690 years to transmit
that's a lot of open models so what thef
do people use these open models for
us hey there I'm Eugene CEO of fedus AI
and co-lead for the RW KV open source
project at fedus we unlimited API
request to over 3,700 truly open AI
models to thousands of users with a $25
a month flat pricing for individual with
access to all our models including the
famous DC R1 with larger plans for scale
up business
users our goal at the $25 price point is
to provide accessibility to all truly
open AI models with the goal of
continuously expanding our catalog to
eventually cover all hugging phas models
all of which give us a unique data and
insight in which how these open models
are actually getting used via platform
the how and the why and by reflection
the open source commit as well so let's
get the pie chart
out let's focus on our individuals users
first for a week in February 2025
unsurprisingly most individuals are
using deeps R1 followed by L tree line
of models the mistro Nemo CH B and the
qu line of models with everything else
effectively Buried one important thing
to note on this data for individual
users is that they are not built or
charged by tokens for feeders we are
instead limiting the plans to one large
model request at a time with smaller
models typically being faster than
larger ones there is no price difference
for individuals here for between the
models the end result is users choosing
their model based on their preference
and Vibes and perhaps the fame of the
model instead of MML or
price and well model classes is exciting
from a model family wall view it is
masking the details in the story so
let's switch our view to models names
instead of model class which give us A
New
Perspective this is where fine tuning
fragmentation let begin where the larger
llama and quen Pai get sliced up into
individual models all with different
personalities and individual use
case however the first surprising
Insight I would make is the stain power
of a model once a model is used in
production because the needs for
business in production and users defer
dramatically in reality most developers
want consistency they want to only
change their model when they choose to
do so or up in to do so not when their
provider decided to do an
update nothing show this better than the
mistro Nemo chelp because while this
chart represents individuals are
intentionally excluded skilled
commercial users for Reon because when
we add it up scale out commercial users
which was previously excluded things
change
dramatically even when you switch over
to the data by model class the dominance
of much smaller M Nemo models which at
this point is over 8 months old and has
been essentially replaced by much larger
and better model is a surprising
observation this is contributed by the
following factors one small models in
general are cheaper at scale B and other
platforms are ours in our case we
provide access to four small models for
the same price as one big
model the stain power of models in
production and tutorials is a lot more
sticky as most people think things that
enters production in in Enterprises
tends to not be changed for quarters or
or even years at a time
you see the mro Nemo model was one of
the early truly open source models with
A2 licensing that surpassed even the GPD
3.5 plus this caused the early shift
from Clos models to open model and more
importantly it was without the Llama
license restriction that many Enterprise
lawyers were rather uncomfortable about
as such one of the side effect was they
became the default model for lots of
cloud platforms including AWS gcp Etc
with hundreds of fine tuning tutorials
and the models was pushed heavily in
replacing existing users GPD 3.5 work
load for the respective Cloud
providers resulting into lots of
production environments today running on
these models despite being it outdated
by today's a standards one thing many
people Miss is that for many commercial
and enterpris SKS once they get
something working reliably at scale
especially once they have the metrics in
place to observe changes and their
reliability and they have prompted it to
99 % plus accuracy they really do not
want to change their system and have it
break overnight sure they can get an AI
engineer to update the system
instruction prompt every few weeks when
a model updates or they can use a stable
model version in open source and here's
the crazy thing not change the
model because if it end broke don't fix
it so another Stand Out literally is the
Lama 2 Lama guard model Lama 2 is up
about 2% of our workload despite having
new newer better versions of this model
for basically everything in in this
model class it's still the go-to model
for AI Safeguard tutorials online
because it it has haven't been updated
and it's being actively used in
production even for new teams that come
online so that bring us to the
topic what do people use open models
for you see despite us being privacy
friendly as a platform we strict no tax
logging as a policy we can infer usage
from the model uh being used and the
metadata for the requesting application
like what else we use Lama card for
other than safe cards more importantly
we can straight up ask our customers and
exchange notes with agre like open
routers which we did and here's what we
see AI usage today sorted approximately
by volume and usage AI for creativity or
friendship AI for code AI for comy UI AI
for write and check GPD very classic AI
for agent and work that is not in the
previous
categories all of this is based on data
that uh used by our customers directly
as individual or as business for
internal usage skill which in some cases
could just mean that it's repackaging
our API as an app for the App
Store or AI web apps or agents that you
play with
online so getting back to it creative
writing AI role playay and contship and
too much smaller extent therapy in
generally this use case represent the
vast majority of noncoding AI requests
represent 30 to 40% of all AI traffic at
any point of time for creative writing
it's apps like norval crafter a tool
designed specifically to outline manage
and draft your novel from the series law
the high level navigation and
collaborative writing on the text with
other humans and AI this segment
obviously is particularly popular with
authors and with the fanfiction
committee a small adjacent segment to
this committee are folks who use AI for
Creative content in games in particular
Dungeons and dragon style kind of
content for the other for the other
group AI role playing companionship we
have apps like Wy chat s Haven and a
whole lots of them while there's a lot
of social stigma around this segment due
to its association with explicit or
sexual content it is still the number
one use case for AI today for non quote
or agent take workf flows and the and
it's the use case with the most number
of active users be it directly or
through the app store which uses our API
under the hood it is also why Sam Alman
and G can't stop teasing about the movie
her because it's still a large percent
of Cl Source AI movie uh
usage also it's 2025 let's get the
gender stereotype out of here cuz unlike
popular belief it's not about you males
over 60% of the users in this segment
are women this mirrors a well known
pattern where romance novels targeting
women is the number one sales of books
by volume by a really huge margin
however you would't see a book stop or
presenting themselves that way due to
the social stigma and stereotype around
it at least for most book
stores likewise the same here is
happening for
AI so to fur Fight The
Stereotype that all this is about R
rated mil content let me quote one of
the app makers
here women tend to use these apps to
hold long conversations and distress
talking about their day-to-day lives uh
every day in part because their real
life partners are either non-existent or
emotionally unavailable for them so ouch
if you worried about AI stealing your
partner learn to talk to her and be
emotionally
available which ties in to another usage
Str that we see therapy and
Jing there are lots of dedicated
commercial apps on the App Store but
when we ask users what apps they use is
heavily fragmented it seems be it before
or after AI silicon value can help but
create another journaling app every
single month one thing to note
separately a good percentage of users in
in our group that we we survey just
essentially said that they use check gbt
clones or their companion apps with a
ter therapy character for the same use
case essentially not being dependent on
a specific therapy or
journaling taking a few steps right into
this broader category there's a reason
why I group all these use cases all
together in general this segment for
this segment no one cares about MML this
segment is all about Vibes Vibes Vibes
and is the use case for a large s of
various Community fine tun various
different names and it's extremely
competitive with top models ranking
constantly changing weekly so what do I
mean by Vibes for one it's ironically
doing the one thing that is the complete
opposite for every AI model instruction
tune it is not rushing to answer the
question or even solve or answer the
question for example in therapy
engineering the job of the therapist or
in this case the AI is to guide and
Empower a client to do what they want to
reach their goal not tell you what to do
the answer has to come from the
individual likewise in story writing
role play and companionship the term
used is Slow Burn no one is watching
Game of Thrones by starting from episode
one and skipping everything by jumping
in the last episode we came here for the
entertainment in between not to talk
about the ending at the dinner
table so well there's a new exciting
flavor for the community every few days
just like there are new books every one
of these models are unique and different
one the model that can go howy and all
cowboy that is the legendary alind
magnum model one a model that
specifically focused on science fiction
something which apparently a lot of
models are really bad at use the Rosa
model given the speed this community
moves the models I name will probably be
replaced by next month
frankly but when talking to the
committee in this space where everyone
plays and hops around model dieses
focusing on the hot new celebrity tune
for the week they sometime return to
their old favorite as one user put it
it's like playing a retro game from the
memories he has his
charms and I will emphasize that this is
a category that has the largest skill
for a sense of skill the current size of
this user base and Community including
close close Source commercial apps like
character. is in the tens of millions
everyone else is not even it's not even
in the millions yet
so the next major segment is coding
co-pilot and coding
agents which is about 20 to 30% of all
traffic in general there are two
segments to this group Auto completion
tools similar to the original GitHub
co-pilot or editing VI chat it which is
basically available natively or through
plin to every ID today you probably not
even considering an ID anymore if you
don't have these features as an
option these features are now being
served by dozens of AI model that are
small and arguably good enough with
parameter size ranging from 3 billion to
12 billion from reply M anly every AI
lab Under the Sun I would argue Auto
completion for code for this part is
essentially solved so the Battleground
for AI and code has moved to more
agented code uh agents and I don't just
mean this swe agent or dein style agent
which is apparently too autonomous and
goes into too many infinite Loops for
many
developers I mean nearly autonomous
agent with lots of clarifying questions
but involve interventions with humans in
the loop kind of agent where humans can
rapidly step in and make a tweet or
suggest changes in chat whenever
something goes slightly wrong the
trending term for this phenomenon is
called Vibe coding where basically you
never touch the code and just keep
chatting and prompting all your
changes also because of how token hungry
these agents can be one thing is known
is how much traffic it ask for compared
to the users of the previous segment a
developer fully in the flow of VIP
coding could essentially generate a
thousand times more input and output
tokens traffic back and forth than a
single person chatting to a companion
model so where there are at most tens of
thousands coders that using these models
at any point of time this traffic volume
is growing ridiculously fast in the past
week one side note to be clear on Cross
referencing data from open router right
now the vast majority of traffic is
dominated by CL Sonet for this use
case and we are not talking about a a
small difference we're talking about
over a 10 to1 ratio here most tools that
support this more atic coding workflow
like cursor is still integrate heavily
towards the more commercial models
however because of the volume of Ru cage
and since the R1 wave we have seen a
rapid growth in using such tools with
open models this is part of the reason
why there is no use for me presenting
generary data because this coding
segment itself went from basically under
the 5% threshold in volume to easily now
20 30% of all
traffic the one major open source
project that sticks out that I would
like to highlight is
client which focuses on the chat agentic
flow and when you combine it with the
other open source project continue there
for the auto completion integration you
basically have the same level of
experience as clot or open a models with
cursor or any other uh ID platforms with
agentic workflow fire R1 or we possibly
using your own private Mech Studio
cluster under the basement extremely
popular for like all these hobby users
who actually want to do this completely
without the internet
highly recommended that you uh give this
open projects a try in vs code before
they get f a dozen times in the next
YC next up is confy UI and friends about
5% of the traffic for personal agentic
workflows well many of you may be
familiar with these two being widely
used in the diffusion space for more
complicated AI Generation image
generation
workflows similar uh graph style based
uis are now B used right from reporters
lawyers music Ians influencers and even
po
somehow where where these people are
chaining complicated workflows to
generate the tax that they want for
their use
case similar to coding agentic workflow
the token explosion from a handful of
this power user slowly stack up to
noticeable
levels but these users are not
developers they are literally like I say
musicians or like all these cretive
personnels who learn how to use these
tools however unlike client which saw a
sudden explosion due to R1 the past few
weeks this has been more about a slow
and gradual user base build up in the
past
months it's also a space like most
agentic platforms uh where it is
essentially what I call a framework War
if for those who are familiar with the
JavaScript
era the next major segment R and LGBT
clones essentially about 20% of all
requests at this point what every
platform be fedus or open router or
every other API provider will have their
own internal check GPD UI our is called
Phoenix a stand up application in this
category that I would like to name is
typing mine and in the application which
surprise surprise builds you with a
one-time fee instead of a subscription
and can be used locally on your laptop
against any API provider Like
Us in particular is the level of UI
polish and how they've been keeping Pace
with cloning every single chat GPT UI
feature into their app and customizing
that with even their own plugin system
beyond that you probably heard this use
case a thousand time ch gbt right y so
let's skip to the one that everyone
wants to hear more about AI for agents
and work representing 10 to 20% of all
our traffic because agent is such an
over abused term today I'll split this
into two major categories to make things
clear workflow automation on Arrow
agents and fully automated
agents if I uh so right now let's start
from workflow automation on Arrow agent
for most of you who's working on agents
in Enterprises your number one priority
now is to get all your agents into
production by maximizing Roi for your
company and shareholder value if like
use item without limiting the negative
impact especially since we are in New
York lots of financial institutes are
risk averse by default with many of you
potentially working in developing your
agents right now so have that stands
buil in human Escape hatches by
default what I mean by that is basically
if you're building an automation system
in your
company like way more make it so that
the human can take the driver seat
needed from day
one so for example we work with a few
Insurance claim companies and logistic
companies advising them on how to fully
and automate their email process which
is the part of their
work a common pattern we advise them
would be them to create an AI agent and
UI for fully automating drafting
responses for inbound emails checking
against inventories checking against
rules checking a lot other things in the
process and build a platform you have
for editing and finalizing and sending a
response in best case scenario if the AI
did everything perfectly it's just all
about clicking send and sometimes these
things are built on top their existing
customers
Salesforce or Erp
system however more importantly it at
least have one human checking the final
submissions before it hits the the end
user when done right at launch the AI is
able to successfully drop around 80 to
90% of the response with humans
rejecting emly taking over the remainder
so there's no harm to everyone else
productivity for the responders shoots
through the roof management is Happy the
AI is
adopted and if any any mistakes were
made and the human field to correct it
well that's kind of the human spot not
the
AI over time as confidence start to
build they then start to add
classification for certain known
reliable use case and eventually start
fully automating those use
cases it's like auto reply to certain
certain
scenarios with full confidence after
having seen the system run for thousand
of
customers on the flip side teams that
went full fully ambitious into full 100%
automation without human Escape
Hedges sometimes they start with a
successful launch because everyone
wanted it to suce but more company as
they run the system and as more users
use it they eventually get fully burned
by an angry customer for a really bad
automated response down the line in some
cases this may be fully acceptable
compromise that management accepts from
the start because the savings benefit is
worth it
other times this kills the entire AI
project essentially postponing AI
adoption in your organization for
another year a scenario that you do not
want to
happen and this is commonly because
these a lot of teams end up developing
an entire fully automated workflow
without trying to mooving into
production early that's why I say your
goal is to go beyond the PC phase and in
to adoption in your company at scale in
some portion as fast as possible and to
inter uh integrate and iterate from
there so that leaves the other mythical
category where which everyone loves to
chase fully truly 100% reliable agentic
agents that is fully
automated just don't it does not exist
everyone has who has done it tried to D
it has got
burnt and it we are not
and we are talking about things in
production not
PC the mindset that we should be
thinking when we try to build AIS into
production is that we should approach
things of like trying to solve the 80%
with Escape hatches along the
way because at even at
80% for some of you Mega cops here
that's already millions in productivity
and
saving furthermore do I need to remind
you that even humans are not 100%
reliable so only do this when the
eventual mistake right is acceptable and
can be
fixed and it's a basically a trade off
they willing to take so common example
is co- calling systems when you're
actually willing to lose a lead because
you did you wouldn't have gotten
otherwise anyway or sometimes customer
support because you can get a human to
apologize later
but rewinding back is like you should
take the approach just like how Google
software reliability Engineers or any
reliability engineering for industry
where safety and reliability is
Paramount
do start with an extremely streamlined
reliable system for your 80 to 90%
scenarios and after you're done do it
for another 80 to 90% for that 10 to 20%
failure scenarios and repeat this
process 10 times and now suddenly you
have 99.998% reliability
if if you're an airliner that's not
boing do it another 10 times and
everyone is happy with incremental gains
and and improvements it may not be the
sexy first launch it may not be the most
wild to do it this way but at the r
least your project survives to
production you have huge impact to
Roi and you can iterate from
that and more importantly incrementally
approved and amusingly properly never
change some of the models that you use
and forever give me business which I'm
only going to do and say the following
hey featherless customers especially the
more enterprising ones please try to
upgrade from Lama 2 to something newer
this year or next if done right it's
probably a free 99 to 99.9% Improvement
I know all of you are using this model
and came to us in part because we are
one of the last few providers to host it
and we forever will but hey I'm giving
this advice it's free real
estate similarly hey for closeup slabs
it's
2025 you do not need AGI to learn how to
use G version from AI
models I say this is all seriousness
because for companies in production who
is trying to incrementally improve with
each St to 99 plus 99999 per. it's
nearly impossible to do so if you change
the model every
week so with that H shs I'm out of
time all the best in building your AI
agents Hey Hey Eugene come back here
you're forgetting the one more thing bit
ah crap he can't hear me the laptop
speakers are muted and I have no control
over that you see us AI may be flawed
but honestly we are probably more
consistent and reliable than humans are
as you can clearly see uh oh well here
goes me saving the day hi am quirky a 72
billion parameter linear Transformer and
a tension Transformer hybrid with a
completely new architecture that runs at
less than half the gpu's compute cost of
other Transformer models the strongest
post Transformer hybrid to date when
Eugene proposed training a post
Transformer model to provide an
alternative to attention is all you need
which runs at a fraction of the
inference cost many of you said it can't
be done the tech is unproven and will
not scale well deep seek cost 10 million
uh quirky cost only a 100,000 to build
you can find out out more about our
model at the following link more
importantly as we enter the array where
the average AI model has better MML then
the average office worker The Benchmark
has lost its meaning after all how many
of you audience can calculate orbital
re-entry from Earth to Mars or PhD math
questions all of which are questions
apparently Frontier AI models are now
capable of how many of our AI agents
today can be reliably be trusted with
one task it's instructed to do so
without hallucination or failure I think
you get the point what we find more
exciting is exploring a future where we
take advantage of linear Transformer
models as a means of persisting memories
customization and improving reliability
for future AI models to make useful AI
agents and if you would like to run
featherless or quirky in your private
cloud or on premise environment reach
out to us and we would like to hear more
about your use case